this episode of fun science is brought
to you by brilliant oh wait where is the
F who who's got the f okay everyone
makes mistakes in this episode oh it's
fun yeah now although we all mess up
from time to time when we do make
mistakes we tend to blame ourselves
which seems logical right but to what
extent are we really at fault for the
errors we make for example take some of
the past scientific mistakes we've made
some people used to believe that the Sun
revolved around the earth today we know
that this isn't true from a celestial
perspective it's obvious to us that the
earth and the other planets revolve
around the Sun however based on our
day-to-day sensory experience it kind of
makes sense why people might have made
this mistake as from here on earth we
experience the Sun as being the object
that moves through the sky
from an evolutionary point of view we
use our senses to gather knowledge about
the world in order to survive but can we
always trust our senses to give us an
accurate picture of reality where I love
to chile's take light for example our
eyes are adapted to detect a visible
light but this is only a very small
portion of the electromagnetic spectrum
our eyes generally can't detect other
electromagnetic waves like infrared
ultraviolet or x-rays but if they could
we'd be able to see way more of the
stuff that is actually all around us
okay
so maybe we don't see everything but we
at least notice the obvious stuff right
well in a study carried out in the 90s
participants were asked to watch a video
of people passing balls and count how
many times the ball was passed between
one of the teams for example the people
wearing white however what Harvard the
participants failed to notice was the
person in a gorilla costume the walks in
part way through showing how we can fail
to see the obvious stuff when our
attention is elsewhere however even if
our senses were as precise as our most
advanced equipment could we ever
guarantee 100% accuracy
well according to an idea known as
fallibilities we can always be mistaken
in anything we think say or do no matter
how certain we might believe we are and
in terms of science that actually means
that technically no scientific theories
are ever really proven to be true wait
Wyatt are you seriously saying that all
the science I learned in school like all
those theories like gravity evolution
the Big Bang but they may all be wrong
yes
[Music]
so the reason I was taught about the Big
Bang in school is because nobody's
proven that very wrong oh thank God I
was about to unsubscribe man it must
suck for the scientists who find out
their theories are wrong
well while there might be the case for
the individual scientist on the whole
when mistakes are discovered in science
[Applause]
it's actually as valuable to the process
as any other scientific discovery
so yes everyone makes mistakes but the
next time you mess up why not try
treating your failure like science does
as something you can learn from making
mistakes their own kind of success now
of course if you do just want to make
less mistakes the best way to avoid them
is by practicing and if you want a great
place to practice your science knowledge
why not check out brilliant the neat
thing about brilliant is that because it
gives you problems to solve it can help
you to learn in an active way which
means that when you do end up making
mistakes you can actually learn from
them they've got loads of different
science courses to check out but if
you're interested in how fallibilities
factors into the scientific method their
science essentials course might be a
great place to start to learn more go to
brilliant org forward slash fun science
and sign up for free although the first
200 people who go to that link will also
get 20% off an annual premium
subscription and that's all for now
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you next time bye bye